by what's the inevitable conclusion of
that Ponzi scheme it just keeps getting
worse that's what that's what we have
right now so like you look at the
difference between the
2007-2008 uh the the
um the housing price bubble that then
crashed and then caused the whole ripple
effect to the recession which then led
to the whole concept of too big to fail
and the tarp bailouts at a zero to that
and that's what we're this is a whole
you know this is an exponential this is
a whole order of magnitude higher of
what we're facing now like we're
literally instead of hundreds of
billions and trillions we're now talking
trillions and tens of trillions and it's
hard to quantify what the Ripple effects
are going to be and they just keep
feeding into it and that's why you see
this this you know they talk about the
uh um the uh yes yes I love this 40 of
all the money that has ever been made
has been made in the last two years this
is also savings yeah you can explain
this spike is when they said your
savings account account is now a
checking account so they put savings
into circulation okay so uh but look at
this the hockey stick yeah that's the
creation of currency and they they I
think they did that to me yeah no it's
it's they were about to start printing
get that upper uh diagonal that big one
that what is it like a 80 degree angle
instead of a 2017 yeah to make it look
less severe yeah and I'm glad you
pointed that out because this doesn't
look like a 40 increase this looks like
a 600 increase but it's right it's the
definitional change that happened thank
you for so what we got to do is get a
graph where we remove the vertical line
and just watch it go from the 27 degree
angle to the 80 degree angle it's still
ugly yeah it's still not good and this
is only up until 2020 like August of
2020 it looks like what's going on now
and what's what's funny is the uh
fractional Reserve policy changed just
before covet yeah it was like in April
2020 or something it used to be that you
needed a reserve to lend load up money
and then they went we're getting rid of
that you can just loan as much as you
want yep yep zero percent right
fractional Reserve imagine playing a
game of Monopoly and all of us are
playing by the rules okay and every
single I'm gonna make you the bad guy
here sorry
um all of us all of us are playing by
the rules right like you know you you
roll your dice you go the number of
things you go to the number of of uh
that you number of spaces you decide
whether you want to buy hold whatever
and then when it's Mary's turn uh she
goes to the banker and says give me a
trillion Monopoly notes and stick them
all with the bill for it that's our
economy
and the the problem is the price of of
living is going up the same for everyone
but the closer you are to that money
supply at its initial printout at its
initial disbursement the less affected
You Are by the double digit price
inflation and the the more you're
exposed to the triple quadruple digit
increase overnight of your wealth and
that's what we're seeing here here's
another important factor here
um
Bitcoin dropped I think to like 19k or
whatever yep and everyone's screaming in
the media and I'm just like I don't know
I don't care I'm ignoring it and that's
the deal when you have money you don't
care that it went down you're like I
don't know what I'm gonna do with it
anyway yeah and then after a year two
years three years it starts to recover
so when people see this stuff and they
actually need their money and they're
seeing it tank and they're like I can't
ignore that and they're forced to sell
it at garbage rates they become poorer
yeah rich people who are more resilient
to the change in monetary value and
recessions and depressions can ignore it
until the recovery happens and then
retain all that value yeah so the rich
get richer the poor get poorer exactly I
would also like to note that Bitcoin has
crashed down to its 2017 High its
previous all-time high before this last
increase there's an old video I wish
they had kept updating it it's about
seven years old now but it's called
don't buy Bitcoin it crashes and it's
this guy going there was this one time
Bitcoin was worth and I'm making up the
numbers but it's pretty much like this
one time it was worth uh point one uh
sense and then it went up to five cents
and then it crashed all the way down to
two cents and then this other time it
was worth three dollars and 25 cents and
then it went all the way up to 25 and
then it crashed all the way down to 780.
and like he keeps doing this and he goes
and so the moral of the story is don't
buy get rip coin it crashes this is the
the uh the uh cycle of parabolic growth
usually some sideways trading and then a
crash down to higher than the previous
all-time high and now the gaps are
obviously not as wide as they used to be
it's a lot easier for something to go
from a dollar to ten dollars than to go
from twenty thousand to two hundred
thousand right like there's only so much
market cap it can have but the pattern's
still playing out this is not Financial
advice by the way yeah yeah I'm just a
Jew on the internet I'm not a financial
advisor but you but you look at the way
the dollar is going and I don't know how
anybody could have faith in their
paychecks at this point really yeah the
the recession that's headed our way
that's they're saying there's gonna be
rolling blackouts do you guys see these
report this reporting rolling blackouts
food shortages food prices so it's it's
it you know what you know what I'm
really proud of uh in 2020 I started
doing the emergency food ships yeah and
then like Vice made like a hit piece and
they were like haha what a loser and
then I'm like man if you if you bought
that food in 2020 it was I think like
half the cost of what it is today yeah
so you'd be sitting on food that lasts
for 25 years at half the price you'd be
like oh wow it's a good thing I bought
it two years ago it's we're gonna last
23 more years yeah you buy it today it's
more expensive Jim Baker has the last
left even even if
you just decided to eat it today you got
your food at Half Price yep so it's
crazy because you know I was talking
about this in 2020 2021 food shortages
are coming what happens Putin's price
hike whether or not you believe any of
that stuff the fact is okay there is
there is a shortage of wheat which is
going to it's it's going to be
mind-boggling my mind-bogglingly
devastating not as much to us
but Lebanon you know Saudi Arabia uh all
these these Middle Eastern countries
turkey these countries that get much of
their grain and food from Russia and
Ukraine they ain't going to be getting
it so what are they going to do they're
going to be very very hungry and very
angry and we are going to be watching
we're going to be sitting there and
we're going to be like huh remember when
we used to watch CNN when they were news
no well let's put it on anyway you'll
turn it on and you'll just see food
rights water and food riots and we'll
have some of that here
during the pandemic remember those lines
of cars for Miles waiting for food
because people didn't have any
if you think it's bad now if you think
it was bad back then right now there's
nobody producing no so not only do we
have a fertilizer shortage which which
led to predictions of a crop yield
dropping by 40
diesel potential shortage meaning
Farmers won't even be able to harvest
and if they do it'll be substantially
more expensive to harvest and there will
be substantially less food meaning for
more than one reason the cost of food is
going to Skyrocket yeah it's almost a
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt no I'm
gonna say and then people are gonna are
that's that's when people break down and
go crazy yeah it's almost as if
massively expanding the monetary Supply
and then just handing it out leads to a
massive increase in prices uh because
you have the uh much more money chasing
the same amount of goods and services
and then that same amount of goods and
services actually goes down because
people say I got all this money I don't
need to work and so now you've got the
disruptions from that it's it's a
perfect storm for what we're
experiencing you know what we need
seeing this problem happening yes we
need to like we need to figure out a way
to start over some kind of like like a
reset but a bigger one a great one a
great one great reset yeah like a really
big make resets great again yeah yeah
yeah like a great reset yeah and then
maybe when the people people look people
are going to lose everything they own in
this but we need this great reset yeah
and then after that they may own nothing
but they will be happy you'll be happy
they'll be happy good so it makes you
wonder you said it was great that you
sold me it great honestly but it's
called great that it must be but it
makes you but listen listen it makes you
wonder when they advocate for the great
reset literally like calling it that
yeah and then they Implement these
policies that have just destroyed
everything it's almost like they want it
to happen I'm looking at the M1 money
supply I'm kind of investigating right
now and it does show up until May oh I'm
seeing it up until May of 2022. it's at
the 80 increase until about
uh April 2022 and then it looks like
it's actually gone down yeah because
yeah that's slightly a little bit Yeah
because the Federal Reserve has started
tightening the the rates they've started
increasing the rates the reason that's
happening that is a consequence of banks
being able to lend money or get lent
money at effectively zero percent what
you factor in for inflation they're
actually getting it at negative interest
rate they can turn around and and put it
out there to us to the consumer at a low
interest rate and just make a bunch of
free money basically it's literal free
money so by raising the race and then
buy property with it right bankrupt
people and then seize their assets
destroy their their lives and walk away
holding the bag because people will be
able to pay back the interest on their
loans Etc things like oh once everything
crashes absolutely that's all the
foreclosures that happened in 2007 2000.
we need a lot of protect people from
foreclosures because I imagine BlackRock
and other banks are going to try and
steal people you need to just stop you
need to get first of all you need to get
currency out of the control of the of
the government government isn't
political entity that tries to implement
political goals for political purposes
it should not be in charge of the money
supply because this is what happens when
you have a political entity in charge of
the money supply they create they
implement the money supply not for the
best use of its consumers because
they're a monopoly they don't care about
the consumers or or the people using it
they do it for their political purposes
which in this case is to try to you know
push along a an economy that they don't
want to correct and making things worse
in the process and paying off the
cronies who sponsored them in the office
sure but you have to recognize some
people are just really dumb right oh
there's that too yeah and and because
they're so dumb you need better men to
rule over them strong men strong men
strong men for a great reset why has no
one else thought of this
like it took us coming together to
finally figure out what the problem is
haven't you did you ever don't you
remember that speech from Michael
Bloomberg when he's attacked the poor he
said poor people spend money on dumb
things yes so we should tax their money
so we can choose for them what to buy
that's one message if there ever was
right he wanted to tax large drinks
because he said poor people are stupid
and buy big sugary drinks and get fat so
let's put a big tax on it so they can't
afford it anymore so they stop doing it
that works that works so you said get
money out of the governor out of
politics or what I don't know how did
you phrase it right so the government
needs to stop being involved in what
money is because if you if you allow the
market to determine what money is now
instead of having a political entity
manipulating openly manipulating the
monetary supply for political purposes
right and and destroying the wealth and
the well-being of the vast majority of
people that are involved in this instead
now you have competing entities who
because they want to be you know have
their dominant market share have a
vested interest in doing the opposite
they want their money to be deflationary
or at the very least not go not have the
the value go down over time have them
the value of the money increase over
time have the the case use the ability
to use it uh go up over time have it Be
an Effective and better thing this is
what we apply to everything else right
like you don't want to have to buy your
car from the government car company
right why would you want to have to get
your money from the government money
company hold on sorry real quick yeah
you not only would you have to buy your
car from the government but they have a
computer chip in it where every year it
goes 10 miles an hour slower yes and
then you're alive literally I gotta get
a new car gotta get it too slow yeah
this is like planned obsolescence for
money right so this is like Federal
Reserve tactics which is a private
company obviously they're in cahoots
with the Monopoly they're monopolized by
the government but like Congress is
supposed to be in charge of the monetary
Supply according to Congress yeah so it
should be amended like no that's the
thing like yes this is Con and by the
way this is why I don't consider myself
a constitutionalist I think the
Constitution is a useful way for us to
use it defensively to protect our rights
but at any point there are times in the
Constitution where it lays out things
that blatantly are bad for us and
violate our rights and this would be an
example of that I don't think that
government should be involved in money
they've proven themselves to be a bad
Steward of it and even if you replace
the Federal Reserve because I understand
what you're saying they're technically a
private entity if you replace the
Federal Reserve uh instead with
yes if you replace the Federal Reserve
instead with just a a a federal bank uh
it's effectively the same thing but just
you know with different steps like you
don't need a federal bank that's what I
just handed but we could uh that's the
bank of Columbus ten dollar bill this
was a bank no a private bank credit
right this is what I'm talking about I
think if it was Congress we'd be able to
audit it or it would be like part of it
being the congress's bank is that the
American The People's Bank is that we
would audit it it would constantly be
all public in theory and could it be
better yeah but you still have a
centrally planned Authority right so why
not instead allow a a market-derived
series of notes or in this case it's
probably going to be more electronic but
but you could also have physical notes
there are plenty of people out there
that don't want the the electronic notes
they want the physical notes but why not
let the market determine what is best
for people because the people who are in
power are friends with those who control
the policy that enrich them and why
would they ever walk away from that's
the correct right they collude well no
because people collude and buy up huge
amounts of stuff and then sell them off
all at once and then they they work the
market it and so we need a government to
protect us but that's not what we have
money from the fed and they buy up
houses and then you are a working class
family and you're like it's time to buy
our first house this house is going for
200 Grand and you say I will pay asking
and they go great we'll get back to you
and they call you back and say we got an
offer from you know BlackRock or
whatever that's at 2 40. and you're like
I can't afford that and they're like
well sorry
and that's what keeps happening to
people yeah yeah and the thing is a lot
of what the uh the the crony and at this
point it's sort of like a corporatist
fascist extension of government some of
these companies like BlackRock and and
so forth the reason they're able to do
it is because they get free money that's
underwritten by you and by Future
Generations that haven't even been born
yet you reintroduce and I'm not saying
necessarily this but you reintroduce
having the money being determined at by
the market level they have to play by
the same rules as the rest of us and yes
they're wealthier but they're now going
to have to deal with the same supply and
demand issues they're not going to be
able to just yeah Bitcoin they're not
going to be able to just print out
endless streams of money and have you
pay the bill for it have you pay the
debt for it with the interest and uh you
know and then when everything falls
apart they get bailed out and that's
paid for by more money that got printed
out that whole thing goes away when you
take away the ability for them to just
expand the monetary Supply whenever they
want to to pay off their own right this
is why I like cryptocurrency people this
is why it's frustrating when you get
progressives who are acting like
crypto's a really really bad thing
people's like you're just established
you're just you're just chilling out for
the establishment people literally the
way out people can create infinite
amounts of crypto right now without
regulation absolutely that's endless
inflation just the same
problems
exactly it comes into this is subjective
value right like I can make a coin
Tomorrow based on the ethereum chain or
whatever I call it Spike coin and I go
hey everyone go get some spike coin and
they go great what's your what's your
case use what is your what are you
fulfilling that isn't already being
fulfilled I go Spike coin that's not
gonna work No One's Gonna Want It some
people will get it as a joke but it's
not going to go anywhere it's it's and
on top of that I can I can print a bunch
of cards and I can call them uh Tim
bucks yeah and I could be like this is
paper Tim bucks they're worth so much
money hey and people are going to be
like I don't know if I value what I
value it if you value right now all the
people with the Bitcoin and the ethereum
like they're huge people that own
massive amounts of that stuff would own
the market essentially without any
government oversight and then they would
buy up all the corn and then they would
raise the price of corn 13 times and
then some sell it back to the people
well first of all just I mean yeah are
there Bitcoin billionaires absolutely
but like the if you look at like the the
distribution of that wealth for lack of
a better term uh it's far less
centralized than you would see for
example where you have like what is it
less than one percent of the population
that owns 20 30 of everything like
that's certainly not happening and with
if you took all the the crypto Bros out
there
um they're certainly not going to have
anywhere near that same uh Market level
that would that exists in this current
system because they can't because it has
to be a system that reflects the actual
Market demands and supply and demand as
opposed to a political entity a
centrally planned political entity
saying all right well you guys help get
me into office and so you know I'm
paying you off and here's however many
trillion dollars I'm gonna give you a
600 check you stay right there you
should make sure to vote for me and uh
and you know also you're getting the the
debt for this guy uh oh this all fell
apart okay well um we're gonna print out
more money and bail you out because
you're too big to fail you've got to pay
for this you're definitely not too big
to fail that's the system yeah that's
the worst the uh Federal Reserve on
unauditable system is the worst by far
but I think that crypto unregulated by
the people would be as could get as bad
the the reg
there is no utopian system but the
regulation comes in place if suddenly
there's a reason for for there to be
suspicion of how Bitcoin is being used
it's out in the open and people can see
it or if it's not out in the open if
there's some coin that you know you
can't see the back end of it you can't
see The Ledger of it it is centrally
controlled people are going to say why
would I use this when I can use this
that's so much better that's what
happens from the market it's like it's
like using the car analogy if you if if
this car company suddenly is making cars
that are absolute garbage you know it
and you go buy a car somewhere else you
can do this with anything chicken
sandwiches of you know skateboards
whatever it doesn't matter like having
more providers makes it bet makes you
more likely to be able to get a better
value and for them to have an
incentivization of serving you as the
consumer but when you when you bypass
that through Central planning now they
don't have to serve you as the consumer
they only have to serve the political
class that they put in office
I'm interested in getting uh Mary I know
you're an expert on fiscal policy and
fintech so what are your thoughts on all
this
think of the right questions
uh
it's very esoteric a little bit
well with the with the wallets like with
crypto wallets it looks like there's a
lot of people that because everyone has
a wallet but it could be one guy that
has 900 000 wallets I mean it
this argument doesn't track look I
couldn't I could buy a bunch of rocks
and then I can go around being like Tim
rocks their only mine and you can't get
Tim rocks from anybody else so if I buy
a bag of gravel it's true that bag of
gravel is exclusively to me he could own
all that I own them all and then people
are like we want it we want it oh like
we'll give you bread we'll give you
labor and I'm like haha giving out rocks
that's no difference between that and
anything just use Bitcoin as your
example so well Bitcoin is decentralized
it looks naturalized I can right I can
buy Bitcoin and then I've actually put
money into the system and then I would
not just want to lose the value of that
yeah so other people can value because
they know there's a market around it
with real value or people are willing to
buy it at some point farmers are gonna
be like we accept crypto you but great
what kind and they'll choose we accept
Bitcoin we accept ethereum and if you
don't have those two cryptos then you
exchange it for that but the value of
those are going to Skyrocket who owns
them when they decide it's this proof of
stake thing that what they want to move
towards away from proof of work who's
creating tokens is who has the tokens
those are the ones that can to make the
decisions to people to have them yeah
those are the ones that are rich right
now they want to move it to a system
where the rich people get to make the
decision right so what's going on right
now what could happen I'm not saying
it's what we have right now is it ass
it's terrible what could happen is that
people build faith in a cryptocurrency
that is centralized and controlled by
Rich powerful people
that doesn't change the fact that the
FED is bad and we should find an
alternate system and crypto is pretty
good yeah so Market derived systems
don't necessarily not allow for the
centralization of wealth but in order to
be able to do that you have to serve the
consumer if it's Market derived and not
centrally planned in order to be able to
grow maintain and expand wealth you have
to be serving the consumer better than
your competitors especially if you want
to expand it if you want to maintain it
you have to at least be doing it as well
as your competitors in a system that
isn't Market derived in a system that is
centrally planned through a centralized
Monopoly of violence such as Government
instead what you have is a system where
I don't have to serve you I just have to
be friends you're the bad guy again I
have to be friends with Mary the
government who I just so happen to
bankroll into office and friend Mary too
who's on the other side other side and
uh and make sure that they're my friends
and that they give me whatever I want so
now instead of having to to do the often
you know mind-numbing labor to make sure
that I am serving you and everyone else
as best as possible and where the
consumer is King instead all I have to
do is spend a pittance of those
resources just keeping them in office
keeping them fat and happy and then
getting them to give me whatever I want
that is inherently A system that feeds
everything has to feed a greed a profit
motive thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there